Montana
necesario
[música]
Hacía mucho tiempo que no veía tanta gente
el ejército ruso no ocupa
territorio ucraniano
toma todas las medidas para salvar vidas
y seguridad
los civiles enfatizan que las huelgas
se aplica sólo a las instalaciones militares y
armas de precisión excepcionales
[música]
nuestro personal militar combate de inmediato
estar de pie con plena comprensión que tiene razón
su dinero incluso después de herir a los soldados y
oficial quédese en la fila quiero decir eso
una operación militar especial está en marcha
estrictamente de acuerdo con el cronograma de acuerdo con el plan
todas las tareas asignadas
resuelto con éxito
[música]
nuestro
[aplausos]
él